bonsoir à tous et merci de nous
retrouver pour ce nouveau numéro du 7-8
week-end tout de suite le sommaire de ce
vendredi 25 mars
olivier fricher aux membres bénévoles du
festival jazz à toute heure est en
plateau pour nous parler de ce festival
itinérant qui se déroule en vallée de
chevreuse jusqu'au 10 avril
nous reviendrons sur la programmation de
cette 18e édition
jean-emmanuel charreaux administrateur
du château de breteuil nous rejoindra
aussi dans quelques instants
il nous présentera la programmation
spéciale du château pour les fêtes de
pâques avec une grande chasse aux oeufs
une tradition sur ce site et enfin autre
tradition les grandes eaux musicales de
versailles est le début de ce vendredi
dans les jardins à la française comme
chaque année les 15 bosquet du site
s'ouvre au public une idée sortie pour
votre week end
olivier olivier fricher ou bonjour merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation
je le disais vous êtes donc le membre
bénévole de l'organisation du festival
jazz à toute heure 7
c'est un festival itinérant qui se
déroule jusqu'au 10 avril donc dans la
vallée de chevreuse et c'est cette année
la 18e édition un mot peut-être pour
présenter ce festival
oui alors je suis l'un des bénévoles du
festival puisque le festival jazz à
toute heure regroupe 130 bénévoles
autour d'une idée originale de michel
beaucage marchand qui a créé ce festival
il y a dix huit ans maintenant c'est la
dix huitième saison du festival chaque
saison représente une douzaine entre une
douzaine une quinzaine de concerts donc
c'est vraiment un très grand nombre
d'artistes qui sont venus se produire
chez nous donc notre festival c'est
beaucoup de passion c'est la rencontre
avec un public passionné qui nous suit
finalement qui se renouvelle au gré des
différentes couleurs musicales de la
programmation pour un festival itinérant
alors je n'étais pas là l'origine du
projet c'est le projet donc de michel
beaucage marchand qui je pense voulait
pouvoir monter des partenariats avec les
différentes communes de la vallée de
chevreuse du parc de la vallée de
chevreuse et puis offrir des
possibilités différentes et des lieux
d'accueil qui à chaque fois ont leurs
particularités et aussi des partenariats
avec les municipalités de ces communes
qui nous accueillent d'accord donc ça y
est vraiment répartis sur l'ensemble de
la vallée de chevreuse
c'est un festival qui a la grande chance
d'être parrainé depuis son origine par
un grand nom de la vannerie
oui par monsieur andré de chez caris que
personne ne présente parce que c'est
vraiment le batteur français le un
aimant ce musicien qui qui nous fait
l'honneur de nous parrainé depuis depuis
18 saisons qui chaque année se produit
dans le festival avec des musiciens de
tout premier plan qui l'invitent et pour
à chaque fois nous faire nous offrir un
spectacle sans cesse de qualité
croissante
c'est vraiment un soutien important pour
ce festival oui bah c'est un soutien
important bien sûr parce que parce que
monsieur ciccarelli un renom planétaire
et puis surtout il a mille contribuer à
toute la qualité de de ce festival
alors festival jazz à toute heure
festival de jazz forcément mais le à
toute heure justement c'est pour offrir
une vision plus éclectique de cet
univers oui effectivement on est pas qu
anthony dans le jazz pur et dur
la programmation de michel s'ouvre sur
beaucoup de styles musicaux qui sont
toujours des styles choisi des styles
autour de son acoustique de son de
qualité de voix de d'instrumentistes de
très grand talent et on a on reçoit sur
le festival des artistes qui ne sont pas
nécessairement complètement centrée sur
le jazz mais qui offre toujours une
musique de très grande personnalité très
grande originalité
alors on va justement parlé de cette
programmation qui va quoi jusqu'au 10
avril prochain première date ce qui nous
intéresse c'est ce soir ce sera saint
rémy les chevreuse à 21h pour un
spectacle au queen of earth rosemary
standley on écoute un extrait sein des
mairies monde est imminente
bahrein - meritus dès maintenant
alors ce sera donc ce soir à 21h à saint
rémy les chevreuse vous pouvez nous en
dire un peu plus sur ce beau spectacle
donc b rosemary standley c'est la
présentation d'un spectacle qui est à la
fois musical et théâtral les chansons
sont entrecoupées de sketches le tout
dans un décor et des costumes appropriés
donc c'est un tout un spectacle qui a
été travaillé dans un esprit music hall
on vous avez entendu la voix de rosemary
stanley qui est donc une la chanteuse du
groupe moriarty et kiki à cette voie
très très profond des enveloppes et
envoûtante effectivement oui alors
également une autre dette qui va arriver
très rapidement vu que ce sera demain
samedi 26 mars ce sera 21h toujours à
saint rémy les chevreuse vous pourrez
retrouver tanita karam
on écoute
il
c
à défaut
tannis tati karam ce sera donc samedi 26
mars à 21h comment se déroule justement
la programmation donc la programmation
est élaborée hors festival pendant tous
tous les mois qui suivent notre festival
puisque notre festival cours de début
mars à début avril
donc à la fin du festival michel
beaucage marchand se met en quête de
trouver la programmation de la saison
suivante et l'abord tous tous les
contrats avec toutes les lignes et tous
les producteurs
on vient de voir les deux prochains
temps forts du festival ce qu'il y aura
également d'autres temps forts
importants à ne pas manquer alors il n'y
a que des temps forts c'est ce qui fait
notre notre charme j'espère avec blues
caravan là c'est un c'est un
regroupement de trois chanteuses du
label refree cordes qui reprit cordes
montrent une tournée internationale
autour de ces de ces trois chanteuses
c'est un projet qui est que refree
cordes renouvelle régulièrement
je crois que c'est la troisième fois que
blues caravan ne va passer par le
festival jazz à toute heure donc trois
jeunes femmes qui vont chanter du blues
et de la soul
donc là rendez vous près avec le public
parce que ça va être très très très
envie en soi très une ambiance très très
forte
j'en suis sûr ensuite nous recevrons les
glossy sister's donc là on est dans la
tradition vocale des chanteuses de jazz
type andrew sisters 's&p' ou pini
sister's récemment et d'autres qui
chante sur le
le standard d'avoir ces voix féminine à
trois voix un sondage à streatham très
très particulier mais peut-être une
autre date la dernière également robin
bennett donc robin bennett qui va venir
le 8 avril et qui elle aussi a une
personnalité très forte avec un son
acoustique avec une très très forte
présence et un look années 50 un parfum
années 50 dans son style musical le
festival jazz à toute heure à retrouver
jusqu'au 10 avril dans la vallée de
chevreuse vous avez bien sûr toute la
programmation à l'adresse qui s'affiche
à l'écran
olivier frichot merci merci d'avoir
répondu à nos questions merci et sans
transition plus que quelques jours pour
profiter de l'exposition art fluence de
la ville de guyancourt qui vient de
lancer la première édition de son
concours d'arts visuels 90 artistes ont
été retenus pour exposer 160 oeuvres
visuelles dans la salle des expositions
de la ville technique mixte numérique
artisanale photographie dessin peinture
ou encore estampes autant de techniques
qui pouvaient concourir à la première
édition du concours d'arts visuels arts
fluence de la ville de guyancourt
l'exposition rassemble deux événements
qui se pratiquait la ville de huy en
cours
le salon des automnales qui se situe au
mois de novembre de chaque année et le
concours réflexe qui était dédiée à la
photographie qui se situait lui au mois
de février chaque année on a décidé de
rassembler ces deux événements pour en
créer un seul ici un grand événement qui
rassemble toutes les catégories d'arts
visuels à la salle d'exposition 190
artistes amateurs se sont inscrits au
concours 90 d'entre eux ont été retenus
par un jury de professionnels pour
exposer leurs oeuvres dans la salle des
expositions de guyancourt jusqu'au 26
mars prochain dans le cadre du concours
différents prix ont été remis par le
jury présidé par marc j minier il y à un
jury qui s'est réuni le 20 février 2016
pour attribuer les différents prix et
pour sélectionner les oeuvres exposées
donc les différents prix ont été
attribués à des artistes qui sont
exposés
il y a comme je le rappelle le prix
peinture le pré sculpture le prix
estampes le prix descend le prix
techniques mixtes
le prix photographie mais également le
prix de la ville qui ont été décernés
par les membres du jury
le dernier prix à remettre et celui du
public
il sera remis ce soir mercredi 23 mars
l'exposition art fluence sert de
tremplin tous les amateurs qui
souhaiteraient se soumettre à un regard
professionnel
et jean emmanuel charlot administrateur
du château de breteuil vient de nous
rejoindre en plateau bonjour et merci
d'être parmi nous aujourd'hui
alors vous venez nous parler justement
de cette tradition maintenant qui est
instaurée au château de breteuil pour le
week-end de pâques avec la grande chasse
aux oeufs c'est vraiment une tradition
rendez vous pris 1 avant tout à fait je
pense que d'une année sur l'autre
beaucoup de familles reviennent à
breteuil
ce sont les grandes chasses aux oeufs
puisqu'il y en aura au total 4 sur ce
week end de grande chasse aux oeufs
dimanche de pâques et de lundi de pâques
l'une à 12h30 l'autre à 17 heures
environ 10000 e vont être cachés au
cours de ce week end le cacher à peu
près partout dans le parc
alors non il ya des zones bien
délimitées et nous faisons deux zones
une pour les moins de 6 ans et une pour
les plus de 6 ans pour éviter que les
plus grands tapez sur les plus petits
mais les partisans vous avez aussi des
adultes non limites
ce sont les chasses aux oeufs pour les
enfants donc on va dire qu'à 14 15 ans
c'est un peu moins drôle pour eux je
dirais d'aller chercher les oeufs dans
les fourrés tout le monde est gourmand
mais trouver les oeufs enlevé en les
cherchant au sol c'est on réserve
vraiment ça aux enfants
alors il y a deux deux principes selon
les zones
dans la zone des moins de 6 ans les
enfants devront trouver 3e de couleur
différente sondés en plastique de
couleur il combinaison trois coups de
trois couleurs est à trouver dans la
zone des plus de 6 ans il faut en
trouver 5,5 de couleur différente une
fois que chaque enfant à sa combinaison
de couleurs il vient au stand des
changes et en échange de ces trois oeufs
ou de ces cinq qu'il nous rend on lui
offre des oeufs en chocolat très bien
c'est assez technique et il y a deux
d'or qui sont cachées à chaque chasse
aux oeufs donc si un enfant a la chance
de trouver cet oeuf d'or il a un cadeau
en plus des oeufs au chocolat
il faut chercher il faut chercher les
oeufs de couleurs sont faciles à trouver
les oeufs d'or sont bien cachés donc
quatre chefs je vous le dise
sur dimanche le 26 mars et lundi 27 mars
à 12h30 et 17h tout à fait parfait
et en plus de cette chasse aux oeufs
également il ya différents ateliers
différents types d'ateliers qui seront
vantés est offert à votre public
notamment d une restitution de contes de
perrault en son et lumière alors les
contes de perrault en son et lumière ça
sent en permanence dans le parc de
breteuil dans les dépendances du château
dans les écuries dans l'ancien lavoir le
petit poucet s'est réfugié avec ses
frères dont le l'ancien fruitiers c'est
peau d'âne qui est au lavoir il y à
barbe bleue dans la salle de chasse
cendrillon et le chat botté en son et
lumière sont dans les anciennes écuries
du château
il y à la maison de mère-grand le petit
chaperon rouge à rendre visite au loup
sur le terrain de jeu donc tous ces
contes de perrault qui sont visibles à
breteuil tous les jours toute l'année
évidemment évidemment feront la joie des
visiteurs au cours de ce week-end de
pâques
il y a les conteuses nos conteuses ont
un énorme succès tous les dimanches de
l'année est là et vidéos et tous les
jours fériés également ainsi que tous
les jours des vacances scolaires pour ce
week-end de pâques les conteuses vont
peaufiner leurs discours en plus des
contes de perrault il y aura des contes
de pâques avec des histoires de poules
de coke de lapins de poussins et c'est
alors aussi parallèlement à ses
différents comptes vous avez organisé
des ateliers effectivement des ateliers
pour les enfants un atelier maquillage
parce que les enfants adorent passer
entre les mains d'une maquilleuse et
ressortir avec une bouille tous très
différentes et un atelier confection de
petits paniers pour aller chercher les
oeufs ou denis comme chacun sait un nid
contient les voilà donc les enfants
peuvent confectionner eux-mêmes des
petits nids et rapporter chez eux
le fruit de leur travail ce week-end de
pâques c'est un moment qu'elle vous êtes
très attaché au château de breteuil
oui c'est le juré le plus gros week-end
pour nous de l'année
c'est une marque le début du printemps
le la joie de s'ébattre dans la nature
le parc de breteuil 115 hectares à vie
comme nos visiteurs tout au long de
l'année sa marque le début de la saison
j'irai de plein air voilà des festivités
estivales vouliez également nous parler
jean emmanuel de la programmation et
pour les vacances de pâques
alors oui puisque les vacances de pâques
arrive dans très peu de temps à mi avril
tous les franciliens seront en vacances
et évidemment à breteuil pendant les
vacances scolaires
il y a de quoi satisfaire le jeune
public comme le moins jeunes il y aura
des contes tous les jours à 16h30
donc les contes de charles perrault
trois histoires sont racontées et tous
les jours ça change bien sûr nos
conteuses racontent les vraies histoires
de charles perrault ce qui crée parfois
quelques bonnes surprises puisque walt
disney un peu transformé tout ça et on
est un peu conditionné par walt disney
c'est agréable de redécouvrir le texte
d'origine avec de bonnes surprises à ce
sujet il y aura également pendant les
vacances de pâques des ateliers toujours
pour les enfants confection de couronnes
de fleurs ou un atelier autour des
fleurs puisqu'on ne fera vraiment au
coeur du printemps
et puis à l'occasion de ces vacances de
pâques nous allons ouvrir deux pièces
qui sont qui viennent d'être entièrement
rénové c'est l'appartement de madame du
châtelet qui était grande femme de
science la première programmes de
sciences de france est l'égérie de
voltaire elle était née breteuil à la
grandit à breteuil sa chambre et sa
bibliothèque qui viennent d'être
entièrement rénové et cette occasion
nous exposons un très beau mobilier
d'époque louis 15 qui a été entièrement
restaurée qui somptueux et qui
représente toutes les fables de la
fontaine
là aussi petits et grands peuvent
s'amuser à reconnaître le corbeau et le
renard le loup et l'agneau sur les
différents sièges de ce magnifique salon
et puis en termes d'objets d'art les
vacances de pâques vont également marqué
le retour de la fameuse table de tai
shen des tables de breteuil
cette tablette est vendue au louvre mais
nous avons fait faire une magnifique
réplique j'ai vu les deux côtes à côtes
je peux vous assurer que
la réplique est vraiment remarquablement
bien exécuté comme quoi au 21ème siècle
quand c'est aussi bien faire les choses
qu'au 18e donc cette table la réplique
va reprendre sa place au château ce qui
nous permettra dans le circuit
historique de la visite de raconter à
nouveau l'histoire de ce bijou c'est une
table bijoux qui a été offerte à notre
aïeul le baron de breteuil sous louis
saez en remerciement d'un traité de paix
qu'il avait rédigée voilà donc
l'histoire les comptes
tout ça c'est toujours mêlé sa ravi
petits et grands et ça fait revivre
l'histoire de france de façon ludique
auprès des familles une programmation
donc riche et diversifiée qui vous
attend aussi bien pour le week-end de
pâques que pour les vacances qui
approchent bien vite à retrouver sur le
site du château de breteuil à l'adresse
qui s'affiche à l'écran
merci jean emmanuel charreaux d'avoir
été en plateau avec nous et d'avoir
répondu à nos questions merci on va
basculer également sur une autre
tradition une cette fois ci au château
de versailles
aujourd'hui vendredi 25 mars c'est le
retour des grandes eaux comme chaque
année les 15 bosquet du site vont
s'ouvrir au public les représentations
des eaux des cinquante cinq bassins et
fontaines vont jaillir au rythme de la
musique baroque
un reportage signé michael et demi
d'euros
1666 louis xiv inaugure les premières
grandes eaux de versailles sous le
regard de son jardinier andré le nôtre
et de sa cour
trois cent cinquante ans plus tard les
cinquante cinq bassins et fontaines et
six enjeux de fond toujours la fierté de
la cité royale
chaque printemps les quinze bosquet
s'ouvre au public 72 représentations
musicales sont programmés dans les
jardins de ce vendredi 25 mars jusqu'à
la fin octobre
pour moi c'est un spectacle à part
entière qui en plus nous permet de
découvrir les bosquets comme vous le
savez les bosquets sont autant de
petites pièces dans les jardins de
versailles comme des salons de verdure
que l'on peut découvrir grâce à ses
grandes zones et on peut aussi admirer
ces fontaines qui sont toutes
différentes
donc on a le mélange des arts très cher
à versailles les sculptures les eaux le
dessin des jardins le chemin des grandes
eaux musicales provient également du
mécanisme des fontaines les 35 km de
canalisations hydrauliques sont restées
inchangées les méthodes pour les
actionner date également du xviie siècle
la préoccupation principale des gens
c'est de savoir comment ça fonctionne
parce que les gens pensent que tout
fonctionne avec des pompes donc à ça on
dément complètement c'est encore le
système comme sous l'époque du roi
c'est un système gravitaire n'y a pas du
tout de pompes qui font fonctionner les
fontaines les grandes eaux musicales de
versailles attire entre 10000 et 12000
visiteurs par jour
et comme chaque vendredi le pavé du
canal vous fait partager sa sélection
littéraire aujourd'hui c'est pauline
amis qui vous présente la renverse
d'olivier adam le nouveau roman
d'olivier adam s'intitule la renverse
dans ce nouveau roman on découvre un
personnage qui s'appelle antoine qui est
libraire en bretagne et qui semble avoir
eu une vie ou en tout cas une
adolescence un peu compliqué qui rend un
peu difficile sa relation aux femmes et
en lisant le journal un jour il découvre
la mort d'un homme politique qui l'a
connu visiblement il retourne dans la
ville de son enfance en banlieue
parisienne dans une banlieue
pavillonnaire qui a l'air plutôt calme
où il n'a pas pu se passer grand chose
et on découvre que
antoine a quitté cette ville
lorsqu'un scandale politique a éclaté en
fait s'est révélé que sa mère était la
maîtresse du maire et que tous les deux
ont été mouillés dans une sombre
histoire de violence et de manipulations
sexuels sur des jeunes femmes un petit
peu perdues voilà il a coupé tous les
ponts avec sa famille et va nous
raconter son enfance
ce qui ce qu'il a vécu ce qu'il a
ressenti la relation avec ses parents
aussi le père qui semblait tout ignoré
en tout cas vouloir tout oublier la mère
qui avait l'air innocent non c'est pas
tellement enfin voila il va raconter
tout ce contexte ça peut résonner aux
oreilles de certains parce que ça fait
référence un scandale politique qui a
été révélée assez récemment
donc voilà olivier adam va raconter
toute cette ambiance on n'est plus du
tout dans ses histoires d'amour un peu
bancal comme il a pu faire dans ses
précédents romans
là on est vraiment sur un fait politique
est sur un fait social
et on poursuit avec la rubrique cinéma
tout de suite vos réactions sur les
nouveautés à la fiche de mercredi plutôt
pas mal ce qui explique ce jour de nous
en mieux c'est sympa c'est très
américain pour une explosion peu
scénario c'est divertissant dois dire
hélas superman batman qui se tapent
dessus
bon voilà ça va très très bien
excellence j'ai été bon on n'a peu
spoliés par les bandes annonces
mais le suspense reste de vigueur dans
le film est franchement les effets
spéciaux sont excellents et toujours en
cinéma à geel pineau du grenier à sel de
trappes nous donne son coup de coeur de
professionnels bonjour aussi mal grenier
à sel nous accueillons prochainement le
film la vie des gens un documentaire de
olivier ducret le sujet du film c'est la
dpr l'indépendance et l'isolément des
personnes âgées
le réalisateur suit pendant toute une
année la pétillante françoise une
infirmière libérale elle illumine la vie
des gens avec beaucoup de tendresse
elle fait bien plus que soigner nos
aînés elles préservent leur sociale le
réalisateur sera au grenier à sel le
mercredi 30 mars à 20h30 et le débat
sera terminée à le pallium le pallium
c'est un réseau de santé de proximité
qui accompagnent les malades et leurs
proches
à bientôt au cinéma le grenier à sel et
avant de nous quitter
quelques idées sorties pour votre
week-end ce soir vendredi 25 mars 20h30
direction l'espace philippe noiret des
clayes-sous-bois pour le spectacle de
pierre richard à 78 pier richer joue les
funambules entre sa fantaisie pure et la
vérité dévoilée avec son spectacle
pierre richard iii on regarde quand le
grand blond le distrait passe à la
télévision
je vous jure que c'est vrai le lendemain
il ya toujours un coup you know qui
m'arrêtent dans la rue et qui me dit à
marsala des prix un sacré coup de vieux
depuis hier qu'est ce qui s'est passé
qu'est ce qui s'est passé 40 ans la
broutille
samedi 26 mars retrouvez les équipes
d'impro de déclic théâtre à l'occasion
de leur deuxième match de la saison
trois matches au programme 14 heures 30
pour celui des benjamins 16h celui des
cadets et 20h pour le match qui opposera
les juniors de trappes contre les
juniors du chéné également ce week-end à
lui le festival à tout bout de champ à
l'estaminet de magny les hameaux à cette
occasion retrouver entre autres lors
qu'istres du 7e continent
ce soir vendredi 25 mars à 19h30 pour
une réflexion sur l'écologie en musique
et c'est la fin de ce sept huit
week-ends émission à voir et à revoir
sur notre site internet
on se quitte en musique sur un extrait
justement du grand orchestre du 7e
continent
je vous souhaite un excellent week end